[Musik]
abstand wissenschaft und politik unserer
fachgebiete ich weiß und bin politisch
und wissenschaft was erlauben und jetzt
will ich mal sagen für eine sekunde die
um was erlauben barbara barbara
borchardt neue richterin am
landesverfassungsgericht in mecklenburg
vorpommern ja dort und die
antikapitalistische linke von der
linkspartei in dieses amt quasi
nominiert worden sondern auch gewählt
von allerdings auch mit hilfe der cdu in
dieses amt gewählt worden was echt
heftig ist vor allem vor dem satz in
einem sz interview jüngst die tage
barbara borchardt wörtlich es gab
mauertote auf beiden seiten es sind auch
grenzsoldaten erschossen worden
das ist so genannten mir platzt jetzt
echte hals wirklich darum müssen wir es
jetzt offiziell von seinem eigentlichen
nein geht es heute auch in wind und
daraus wenn sie daraus ein witz mal
mache ich nicht noch mal ein aber sie
haben einmal aber ich verstehe die rede
gerade dann also wir reden doch gerade
über corona mauertote auf beiden sein
es sind auch grenzen oder hat alles gut
kommt es ja getreten die weit offen
stand ich gebe ihnen recht also ich gebe
ich hiermit öffentlich zu protokoll was
kann ich was jetzt gerade mir das sind
ihre gesundheit ihre kranken kumpel hho
aviso dass meine kumpel ich glaube dass
es in der linksparteien zwischen und
zwar inzwischen also damit meint
ungefähr so 20 jahren oder so sind die
allermeisten leute dort nicht weiter was
die verarbeitung dann brauche ich danke
als diese kollegin sie ist auch sehr
weit sie ist nämlich im
landesverfassungsgericht inzwischen
angefangen meine vielleicht hätte sie
irgendwie das fertiggericht wochen soll
die organisation ruhig brauchen alles
gut alles gut
können wir jetzt zu unserem thema kann
also wieder ganz ruhig da draußen ich
bin kalibriert dann hat herr droste hat
osten hat eine studie gemacht das ist
sein job als theologe macht man immerzu
und welche studien und eine studie war
eben von ende april sind kinder und also
die schulkinder und kleinkindern
kindergarten genauso ansteckend oder
weniger ansteckend noch ansteckender als
erwachsene
soweit es um diese krankheit geht mit
der richtig in die politische debatte
hoch politische debatte und auch das
erschließen wir
halten wir sie geschlossen hat der
ausschuss hat rosten derjenige war der
gesagt hat man muss sie schon nicht
schließen wenn man muss die schulen doch
schließt und jetzt hat diese studie
gemacht wo drinsteht es war richtig die
schulen zu schließen weil eben dass das
ergebnis seiner studie richtig dran es
steht nur drin kann ja sein dass die
kinder genauso viel virus verbreiten wie
erwachsene es könnte sein okay für tobi
des kerns also müssen auch mal darüber
reden aber das ist mal der erste stange
und ätherischen stand diese studie genau
und jetzt und diese studie ist aber
jetzt ja sozusagen in seinen
wissenschaftskreisen und dann nähern wir
uns jetzt gleich zu unserem thema die ja
eine andere öffentlichkeit sind als die
öffentliche öffentlichkeit in seinem
wissenschaftskreisen verbreitet worden
und fanden dann natürlich von dort
sozusagen den weg in die große
öffentlichkeit sogar in die ganz und gar
kein cent an die öffentlichkeit nämlich
die bild zeitung mit den ganz großen
buchstaben hat sich sozusagen jetzt
eingeschossen aufwand rosten
warum die das jetzt gemacht haben die
kollegen warum die sich mit den gerade
so aussehe als zielscheibe weiß ich
nicht in einer sache allerdings würde
ich fast geneigt sein chat kommt ja der
'bild'-zeitung fast recht zu geben ein
bisschen denn diese studie die ihr
offensichtlich fehler hat ich kann das
nicht beurteilen ich bin kein biologe
ich lese dass nur und noch nicht so ganz
sicher ist warum ist es ist es klug so
gerade jetzt in dieser situation
halbfertiges wissen in dieser
öffentlichkeit zu pusten moment muss man
als musiker ganz kurz muss man als
wissenschaftler nicht auf die
verantwortung dafür übernehmen dafür das
halbwissen im moment mehr schaden
anrichtet als dass es nützt also eher
frage erstens ist die frage ob es wirkt
da können wir noch mehr schaden als
nutzen stiftet was wir für eine sekunde
bei seite würde ich sofort bestreiten
aber lassen wir würden sie können dabei
sein
es ist halt das phänomen einer wenn man
so will zwangs politisierten
wissenschaft die wissen die politik
fragt in einem takt indem sie
entscheiden muss in so einer krise
wesentlich schnell mit irrsinnigen
volumina also unter 500 milliarden geht
es ja gar nicht mehr komplett
schulschließung das sind ja riesige
hebel räder die da gedreht werden und
natürlich fragt die politik um sich zu
legitimieren und ihre entscheidung auch
quasi vertretbar zu machen vor der
betroffenen öffentlichkeit von diesen
maßnahmen betroffen
bei der wissenschaft nach nur die
politik entscheidet eben in einem tages
takt und die wissenschaft kann natürlich
nicht abschließende erkenntnisse in
einem tagesticket liefern das ist das
dilemma und da kommt keiner raus und
warum können sie es auch keine zum
vorwurf machen wie ich finde
natürlich liefert der osten und alle
anderen übrigens auch das vorläufige im
moment ist es auch vorläufige ergebnisse
ab und sagt achtung das ist vorläufig
und vergisst dabei dass in seiner blase
ist wenn man moment in seiner blase bis
dato immer galt vorläufig da bleiben wir
unter uns und irgendwann kam dann fertig
gehärtete studie raus und er hat nicht
begriffen dass er natürlich jetzt auf
einer anderen bühne spielt obwohl er da
ganz gerne steht oder schlampig ja auch
ganz gerne mag so ist ja nicht die
medien und journalisten nachdem er uns
wichtig dass wir das fest hat es sind
nur journalisten sind alte weiße männer
die mit ihren bedeutungsverlust nicht
zurechtkommt werden wissenschaftler
wer nur angetrieben von der suche nach
der wahrheit und von dem wir uns schon
mal was machen sie jetzt genutzt man
weil es doch weil natürlich sehr einfach
so herum warum landet er könnte sie hat
horstmann ist am tag ist hab ich
irgendwas nicht mitbekommt ist da
draußen von der bundesregierung
beauftragte chef virologe nein wir haben
doch das rk ist eine bundesbehörde die
da hoffe ich dass die pressestelle haben
ich hoffe dass bei der bundesbehörde
vorher einer sehr genau sich überlegt
pressestellen über ist ganz kurz
vielleicht das wissen vielleicht viele
leute pressestelle haben nicht nur die
funktion dafür zu sorgen die
öffentlichkeit zu belügen und
informationen zu manipulieren sondern
präsident haben auch die information
darüber nachzudenken okay vielen dank
lieber herr experte oder kundiger mensch
das ist die info was passiert eigentlich
mit dieser info wenn wir die jetzt in
die öffentlichkeit geben wir formulieren
das so dass die leute das verstehen oder
wir fahren und dann vielleicht bestimmte
sachen auch gar nicht weil die leute das
nicht verstehen
hausherr drosten aber gibt mit so einem
ndr podcast irgendwie zwischen glaube
ich jeder deutsche pflichtgemäß hören
muss immerzu statements ab in einer
öffentlichkeit und immer wird es dann
ärger oder schwierigkeiten
dafür kann ich aber nicht ich bin doch
nur wissenschaftler sorry leute das ist
jetzt das was ihre mitmacht ist ich
hatte nicht mal eines jahres jetzt
stellen sie es einmal andersrum von dann
merken sie wie verzerrt dargestellt
haben stellen sie sich vor allem was ist
eigentlich bild zeitung alle zahlen
alle wissenschaftler würden schweigen
weil sie gewohnt sind erst zu reden
zumindest in der großen öffentlichkeit
erst zu reden wenn sie wirklich was
abschließendes zu sagen haben und dann
würden die wissenschaftler sale leute
bei so einem ding wiener unbekannten
virus das sich weltweit verbreitet ja da
brauchen wir jetzt echt ein zwei jahre
bis wir sagen können was das ist und wie
man da am besten gegen vorgeht und dann
lass uns noch mal ein großen kongress
machen so in drei jahren und dann kommen
wir auf euch zu und sagen euch was sache
ist
man hätte die leute auf dem mars
geschossen schichten der greifen da hat
es das in der lage musste schneller
geliefert wird und man müsste die
fähigkeit entwickeln
mit vorläufigen erkenntnissen umzugehen
und daraus zu handeln übrigens ist dass
das ganze gesicht weil sie können die
schulen hat nicht vorläufig entweder
schließen und sie gleichzeitig offen
halten weil sie nicht wissen in so einer
art des campus kennen sie schrödingers
katze weiß doch jedes kind schrödingers
katze wo man immer nicht was lebt sie so
dass sie tot und wenn so ein quanten
fluktuierenden zustand müssten auch die
schuhe seien ein bisschen offen und
bisschen zu weimann man kann es im
moment noch nicht so genau sagen
und das ist auch gar nicht so ganz klar
ich möchte und muss ich lese tipp geben
in der vergangenen woche ist in der
süddeutschen zeitung für die ich mal die
ehre hatte zu arbeiten ein sehr sehr
guter artikel von gustav seibt ins
erschienen genau zu unserem thema
verhältnis von wissenschaft und politik
da steht noch mal drin dass max weber ja
der große max weber gesagt hat
wissenschaft und politik arbeiten nach
praktisch gegensätzlichen prinzipien und
regeln und herr droste ignoriert das
leider immer zu wenn er seinen blöden
podcast macht und die leute mit
halbfertig wissen füttert es ist in
diesem fall hat max weber rechts sind
unterschiedlich zu ehren des liedes
sondern geht mir auch nicht leicht über
die platte ist ein toller also wunderbar
wenn ein max weber weiß also wovon sie
ablenken wollen ist dass das ganze eben
ein politisches hoch aufgeladenes
hochriskantes spiel ist und sein muss
mit was anderem als mit vorläufigen
wissen sollen sie denn umgehen wenn sie
im wochentakt große entscheidungen
fällen müssen das jetzt nicht zu
begreifen verstehen wird rost nicht da
war doch nicht der liebe gott aber dann
aber christ jahren du musst ein podcast
machen deutschland wartet auf dich so
war es doch machen das doch seine
politik fragt ihn doch nach als eine der
wenigen virologen also bis 50 karten
erst nachgefragt hat die waren in
österreich
das ist doch quatsch und es gibt halt
leider leider es gibt halt mehr
germanisten und lateinamerika nisten als
virologen also reden wir hier über eine
hand voll von leuten von herrn kekulé
herrn strick und herren links die halt
auch noch unterschiedliche meinungen
haben nur eines teilen sie sind alle
ziemlich eitel
das nur das ist auch okay ich habe gar
nichts dagegen dass er seinen ndr
podcast macht ich habe etwas dagegen
dass er durch die tür gezogen wird dafür
dass er arbeitet wie er arbeitet und
übrigens das was er abgeliefert
nachgefragt wird und zwar von der
öffentlichkeit zuvorderst die er auch
mädchen was würde weil sie die zeitung
mit den großen buchstaben nicht wiederum
die rate einmal zu arbeiten mit
wissenschaftlern machen sie sagen wenn
die äußere ich mich nicht ich bin zwar
virologe und ich habe auch lange für
geforscht aber ich freue mich jetzt
nicht etwas sage dann nehmen wir das auf
dann nehmen wir jetzt haben wir nehmen
herrn drosten einfach aber jetzt mal aus
dem aus dem feuer und so rauscht dann
sind vielleicht unsere kollegen das
problem also sie und inflation sowie das
problem aber auch alle anderen weil ich
meine ich kenne so viele journalisten
ein ganz kurz die sich früher mit ganz
anderen sache beschäftigt haben die
jetzt von experten sind für virologie
epidemiologie die können ganz genau
erklären
die reproduktion zu schreiben so riesige
texte darüber wo man denkt alter du
verstehst das nicht nur nicht sondern du
verstehst nicht mal dass du es nicht
verstehst das ist total lächerlich was
ganz viele journalisten gemacht haben
oder was man aber auch witzig dass das
klimaschutz so anders ist ich glaube
über ist die virologen sind die
ungeschulten klimaschützer haben weil
das thema ist jetzt ein bisschen nach
hinten getreten
naja gut was macht man so man hat es ja
gleich verwerten wir haben jetzt wir
haben können 780 millionen hobby
virologen und vorher hatten wir 80
millionen erderwärmung sex perl heim und
es ist sehr wohl vergleichbar weil
natürlich die wissenschaft einig ist in
a der aussage klimawandel erderwärmung
ist menschengemacht man muss was dagegen
tun weil sonst wird's echt fürchterlich
und die anderen wissenschaftlichen
gewissheit bei corona ist dass eine
solche die verbreitete sich rasant ist
tödlich musikern ein echter in der hand
explodieren immer zu spät reagiert das
sind die beiden gehärteten erkenntnisse
und darunter tobt ein munterer wissens
streit wissenschaftler streit unter
anderem auch wie was machen wir dagegen
die atomkraftwerke haben wir nie wieder
auto sie verwechseln und ich haben
betrachten sind langsamen ganz klar nein
entschuldigung es gibt doch erstmal die
festigkeit des wachstums jetzt ein
bisschen gott ja auch jetzt hat jetzt
haben sie mich echt erwischt und ich
weiß überhaupt nicht mehr was ich sagen
soll wo man bei der klimakatastrophe
haben wir 40 jahre lang forschung und
ergebnisse und die haben die wissen
wovon sie reden die können sagen an den
rändern gibt es noch unschärfen aber im
prinzip sind wir uns einig das ist das
ergebnis der politik gesellschaft
weltbevölkerung jetzt macht irgendwas
damit das ist bei diesem virus aber
anders bei dem virus weiß man hat dass
es ihn gibt das weiß man aber ehrlich
gesagt weiß man sonst auch gar nicht so
fürchterlich besonders war es immer
wieder was neues hat immer alles wieder
gesammelt und soll bis ein mann sie nein
nein nein ich bin komischerweise sich
jetzt inzwischen wieder auf seinem
twitter polemik niveau wo ich sage da
kriege ich echt ist herthas wenn ich
nachts beim man meinen nächsten tweet
kriege ich irgendwie so ein ekel anfall
weil die doofheit in diesem medium
sprengt alle vorstellbaren grenzen
lassen sie mal die polemik weg im ernst
wirklich er aber noch einmal der osten
ist er jetzt großmaul oder gott ich
würde mal sagen er ist weder das eine
noch das andere sie arbeitet immer noch
bei der tat habe sie aber in wahrheit
würden gerne großmann hat sehr viele
buchstaben das wohl doch nicht
reinpassen aber jetzt zeige ich nochmal
aber gott oder großmaul und natürlich
ist ja was in der mitte himmel genauso
wie die politik versucht in dieser
ungewissheit in unsicherheit auf
wissenschaftlichen unsicherheit und von
1000 beratern geschossen versucht irgend
einen mittigen kurs zu fahren sagen aber
halten dass man lieber eine woche länger
geschlossen wir hatten das schon mal ob
jetzt wirklich wie unter anderem glaub
ich grüne sagen eine ganze
schülergenerationen verdorben und
verloren ist weil eine woche länger die
schule in meck-pomm zu wahren waren sie
doch mal ein latten am zaun eine ganze
generation ist verloren war eine schule
länger eine woche länger zu hat ihre
kinder sagt selbst schon aus der schule
das merke ich ihnen dabei nicht wird das
aufschlagen
lasst uns doch mal die klos auf den
schulen reparieren von den vielen geld
das würde glaube zum lernerfolg deutlich
mehr beitragen als eine woche früher
oder später auf eine entschuldigung
toiletten studentenstadt starfighter das
auf diesem weg können wir in tränen
[Musik]